- Every lawyer always puts
their client's interest first
and is always a paragon of virtue.
(chuckles) All right, I
couldn't even say that
with this a straight face,
but the vast majority of
attorneys serve their clients
with honor and distinction.
Well, the majority. A
majority of lawyers...
No.
Some lawyers serve their clients
with honor and distinction,
and yet, lawyers have long
been the target of jokes
and media portrayals that depict us
as a uniquely unethical occupation.
- And as for your case, don't you worry.
I've argued in front of
every judge in the state,
often as a lawyer.
- But even though most lawyers
choose the straight and narrow path,
others have broken bad.
So today let's not talk
about those good lawyers
you never hear about,
let's talk about when
lawyers have gone wild.
- And the truth shall set you free!
- So let's start with a
lawyer who defrauds, yes,
a nine-year-old girl with grandpa's help.
Now, one of the cardinal
duties of legal representation
is undivided loyalty to clients.
Under this ethical mandate,
lawyers have a legal obligation
not to enrich themselves
to the client's detriment
and to zealously advocate
for a client's interests
above our own personal desires.
But that's exactly what Vincent
J. Trimarco, Jr. did not do.
He's a Long Island litigator
who conspired with client Gary Eriksen
to slowly steal $2 million of inheritance
from Eriksen's nine-year-old granddaughter
and Trimarco's client, Rebecca Schaefer.
Now Miss Schaefer was
set to receive millions
from a federal wrongful death settlement
involving her father who
died at age 20 in jail
while serving a misdemeanor
for drug charges.
From April 2012 through August 2017,
Trimarco and the
co-conspirator grandfather
orchestrated a scheme to
steal millions of dollars
from a fatherless child.
They purchased luxury vehicles,
including a Ferrari
430 Spider for $200,000
and a Jaguar XKR Convertible for $57,000,
and they spent over $600,000
to purchase several properties
throughout Suffolk County, New York.
And they even invested over
$800,000 of ill-gotten gains
in The Emporium, a now defunct nightclub
and music venue in New York
that Trimarco was at times part owner of.
And while Mr. Trimarco must
have gotten his legal training
from the Lionel Hutz school of law,
Clearly the grandfather
learned his family skills
from Lucille Bluth.
- Oh, don't give me that look.
I happen to be a more
caring mother than most.
- And in October 2017,
federal prosecutors
unveiled 19-count indictment
against Trimarco for conspiracy
to commit mail fraud,
wire fraud, money laundering,
and other charges related to
the multi-million dollar theft.
Grandfather Eriksen, who
died before the investigation
was completed, was named as
an unindicted co-conspirator.
But in October 2020, Trimarco
pleaded guilty to the charges.
In announcing the sentence,
U.S. attorney Breon Peace outlined
why Trimarco's breach
of his fiduciary duty
to his client was so egregious.
Quote, "Trimarco's theft of
a seven-figure inheritance
"from a child so that he
could purchase luxury vehicles
"and invest in real estate is
a disgraceful breach of trust
"and betrayal of his time-honored
duties as an attorney.
"His conduct is an affront to the courts,
"the bar, and the community at large.
"Today's sentence should
serve as a warning
"that this office will
prosecute corrupt attorneys
"who abuse their positions
"and break the law for personal gain."
And in December 2021,
Trimarco was sentenced
to 57 months in prison,
ordered to pay restitution
of $1.5 million,
and forfeit the amount of $1.5 million.
And shortly after sentencing,
the New York Grievance Committee,
which regulates attorney
conduct in the state,
retroactively disbarred Trimarco
as of his October 2020 guilty plea.
But it's not just lawyers
who have gone bad,
it's also judges,
and that takes us to these shirtless judge
who sent explicit photos
of himself to the bailiff
and then impregnated a witness
in his judicial chambers.
Now, judges have this reputation
for being stuffy,
humorless old men in robes,
but in the case of Judge
Wade Harper McCree,
who is neither old, stuffy, nor humorless,
he would still be a judge
if he had kept his robe on
because in 2012, Judge McCree was serving
on the Third Circuit Court
in Wayne County, Michigan,
where he specialized in
sexual misconduct cases.
No, I'm not making that up.
You would think that with that experience
he would've known better
than send bare-chested photo
of himself to a female bailiff.
(person screaming)
This is inappropriate workplace conduct,
and neither the bailiff, nor
her husband found it amusing.
The judge, who was also married,
was confronted with a printout
of the photo by local news
by replying, "Hot dog. Yep, that's me."
(sighs) McCree, whose father served
under President Jimmy Carter
as the second African
American solicitor general
in the United States' history,
was unbothered by the
misconduct allegation,
stating, quote, "I've
got no shame in my game."
Good God, man.
But he later admitted to sending
the photo to other women.
Now, Judge McCree might have been able
to weather this sexting scandal,
but his inability to keep it in his robe
led to a spectacular public downfall.
While presiding over a
child support case in 2013,
Judge McCree repeatedly
used his judicial chambers
for extramarital trysts
with a witness in his case.
- [Lawyer] Between May
and November of 2012,
did you engage in sexual
conduct with Judge McCree?
- Yes, I did.
- Sneak the witness a cell phone
in violation of security protocol
so that he could regularly
text her during trial,
got the witness pregnant,
urged her to terminate the pregnancy,
and then repeatedly lied
about the episode under oath.
- No, it's salesman's puffery.
- Not surprisingly, the
judge was formally removed
from the bench in 2014,
barred from being a judge for six years,
I don't know why only six years,
and following a three-year
suspension of his law license,
the shirtless judge's license
was reinstated in 2020.
So now that McCree has
been given a second chance
at a legal practice, perhaps going forward
he could stand to have just a
little more shame in his game.
But that takes us to the caveman lawyer
who stalked his ex-girlfriend,
repeatedly shoots her
office with a crossbow,
and got disbarred for it.
Now what sets modern man apart
from Neanderthal ancestors
is the ability to work
out disputes using words
instead of brute force.
Sometimes.
But in the case of Steven A. Weinkauf,
this California caveman lawyer decided
that the way to address his hurt feelings
toward his lawyer ex-girlfriend
was not to use his words
but his crossbow,
and it cost him his law
license, his reputation,
and millions of dollars
because in the early 2010s,
Weinkauf began a romantic relationship
with fellow attorney
Adriana last name redacted
when they worked together
in the San Francisco County
Public Guardian's office.
The relationship ended in December 2013,
and while the girlfriend
moved on, Weinkauf did not.
The girlfriend installed security
cameras at her law office
after finding crossbow arrows
shot into her building's windows
in April, June, and August of 2015.
And in January 2017,
surveillance video showed
someone in a red Jeep firing
a gun at the building,
cracking a window.
Five days later, the same
red Jeep drove by at night
and fired another crossbow at the office,
and the girlfriend was able
to identify her assailant
as none other than Weinkauf.
Weinkauf was arrested and
convicted of felony stalking
with enhanced felonies
for using a deadly weapon.
The state bar deemed this
offense moral turpitude
and Weinkauf was disbarred in 2020.
That same year Weinkauf
was found civilly liable
for stalking, intentional
infliction of emotional distress,
and domestic violence
against his ex-girlfriend.
At trial, Weinkauf admitted to shooting
the crossbow one time, but
denied the other incidents
because it was some other
crossbow-wielding maniac.
But not surprisingly,
the jury did not believe Weinkauf's claim
of another crossbower
menacing the ex-girlfriend
and awarded her $1.3 million in damages,
plus over $900,000 in
attorney's fees and costs.
In March 2022, the
California Court of Appeals
upheld the multimillion-dollar judgment.
The takeaway here though
is while there may be
hypothetically situations
where a crossbow can solve your problems,
a broken heart is not one of those things.
Obviously for that you need a trebuchet.
(trebuchet whooshing)
(projectile whooshing)
(crowd cheering)
But that takes us to the Florida judge
who throws down with a public defender
and gets thrown off the bench.
Because when a headline
begins with Florida man
or Florida woman, you
know you're about to read
something that's equal
parts bonkers, hilarious,
and just a dash of "I'm so
glad that that's not me."
(headlines thudding)
But when the headline is "Florida judge,"
well, it's all those
things ramped up to 11,
and such was the tale of John C. Murphy,
a Florida judge who decided
to settle a procedural dispute
with a public defender in the
most Floridian way possible,
by challenging him to a fist fight.
Eh, now that I think about it,
I mean, duel, challenging
someone to a duel
is probably the most Floridian way,
but fist fight is a close second.
- I demand satisfaction.
(glove slapping)
- Oh!
- I challenge you to a duel.
- Hey, a duel?
- Anyway, on June 2nd, 2014,
Assistant Public Defender Andrew Weinstock
and Brevard County Judge John Murphy
we're engaged in a war of words
over Mr. Weinstock's refusal
to waive his client's
right to a speedy trial,
which is a very routine matter
that is typically resolved amicably
in open court with words.
But not this judge.
No, when Weinstock refused to waive
his client's speedy trial rights,
Judge Murphy exploded.
- [Judge Murphy] If you wanna
fight, let's go out back
and I'll just beat your ass.
- Let's go right now.
(attendees chattering)
- [Judge Murphy] Ah! I'm gonna get you.
You wanna (beep) with me.
(attendees chattering)
Do you? All right!
- But Weinstock stood his
ground against the irate jurist,
and that's when Judge
Murphy decided to turn
his pretrial hearing
into a trial by combat.
Unfortunately, as
Weinstock would soon see,
Judge Murphy, a former colonel in the army
and Afghanistan veteran,
had plenty of experience
settling disputes on the battlefield.
Weinstock follows Judge
Murphy out of the courtroom
and into the hallway
as sounds of a struggle
can be heard off camera.
And according to reports,
a sheriff's deputy
witnessed the men gripping one another
around the collars of their
suit jackets while screaming.
The Florida judge allegedly
punched Weinstock in the face
before a pair of deputies
broke up the fight.
Weinstock was reassigned
to another courtroom
to avoid a second confrontation.
When Judge Murphy
returned to the courtroom,
because this is Florida, he
was greeted with laughter
and thunderous applause.
(attendees applauding)
- [Judge Murphy] I will
catch my breath eventually.
Man, I'm an old man.
- But with Weinstock no longer present
to defend his clients,
Judge Murphy obtained speedy trial waivers
from Weinstock's unrepresented defendants,
probably because they
had just seen the judge
pummel the crap out of their lawyer.
- In bird culture, this
is considered a dick move.
- But it's also what
we lawyer guys refer to
as a huge ethical violation.
Judge Murphy issued a public apology,
enrolled in anger management classes,
and took a four-week paid leave of absence
and was reassigned from
criminal to civil cases.
Weinstock resigned in protest
after Public Defender Blaise
Trettis declared his support
for Judge Murphy's return to the bench.
Judge Murphy went viral for the video
and was dubbed the,
quote, "fighting judge,"
but not everyone was amused.
In 2015, the Supreme Court of
Florida removed Judge Murphy
from the bench, overruling
the state disciplinary board,
which, again, I can't
emphasize this enough,
because it was Florida
only had recommended
a four-month suspension
and a $50,000 fine.
The Court acknowledged, quote,
"It is without question that
except for the June 2nd,
"2014 incident, Judge Murphy
had been a good judge."
Nevertheless, the court
concluded that Judge Murphy had,
quote, "surrendered his
privilege" to serve as a judge
after threatening violence
against the attorney appearing before him,
fighting that attorney,
and then inducing the
attorney's unrepresented clients
to accept speedy trial waivers.
Quote, "Judge Murphy's
total lack of self-control
"became a national spectacle,
"an embarrassment not
only to the judge himself,
"but also to Florida's judicial system.
"Given the clear erosion
of public confidence
"in the judiciary cause by his misconduct,
"removal is an appropriate sanction."
And I have to say if there's
one takeaway from this case
it's that not even the honor
of being an elected judge
is enough to overcome the
force that compels residents
of the Sunshine State to
transform into Florida man.
But that takes us to a couple of lawyers
you might have heard something about.
- Good evening, America.
We are Mark and Patty McCloskey.
- They are the Missouri
personal injury lawyers
who spent decades suing
everyone for everything,
then they waved their
guns at BLM protestors,
became MAGA celebrities,
and then they sued even more people.
Now, personal injury attorneys
are often referred to
as ambulance chasers
due to a reputation for
filing costly frivolous suits.
But in the case of Missouri
personal injury lawyers
Patricia and Mark McCloskey,
it turns out all you need to do
is basically look at them the wrong way
and they'll sue you.
♪ I'll sue ya ♪
♪ I'll take all your money ♪
♪ I'll sue ya if you
even look at me funny ♪
- Or they'll point
their guns at your face.
♪ He'll sue ya ♪
♪ He'll put a gun in your face ♪
♪ She'll shoot ya probably
because of your race ♪
- Now, you've likely seen this
viral photo from June 2020
when the McCloskeys pointed
firearms at BLM protesters
marching past their St Louis home.
But that's not their
first public spectacle.
Here's how Jeremy Kohler
of the "St. Louis Dispatch"
described the couple following
a review of public records.
Quote, "The McCloskeys are
almost always in conflict
"with others, typically over
control of private property,
"what people can do on that property,
"and whose job it is to
make sure they do it."
Now, among there many, many legal fights,
it includes suing to obtain their home,
a castle originally
built by Adolphus Busch,
co-founder of Anheuser-Busch,
suing a man who sold them a Maserati
they claimed was supposed to come
with a box of hard-to-find parts,
and fighting their HOA to
acquire 1,100 square feet
of a triangle of lawn
designated as a common area
for the neighborhood.
Now, one notable McCloskey dispute
bordered on cartoon villainy.
In 2013, Mark McCloskey
allegedly destroyed beehives
placed outside his mansion's northern wall
by the neighboring Jewish
Central Reform Congregation,
then left a note saying
that if the mess wasn't cleaned up quickly
he'd seek a restraining
order and attorney's fees.
The congregation was
planning to harvest the honey
and apples on the property
for the Jewish new year,
and according to Rabbi Susan Talve, quote,
"The children were crying in school.
"It was part of our curriculum."
Now, Mark McCloskey denied
destroying the hives,
and a Snopes investigation
was unable to confirm
who killed the bees.
- No! Not the bees!
Not the bees!
- Now flash-forward to June 2020
when a group of several
hundred BLM demonstrators
marched on the home of St.
Louis Mayor Lyda Krewson.
Mayor Krewson had
triggered fierce backlash
when during a Facebook Live post
she read the full names and addresses
of George Floyd protestors
who had written letters
encouraging her to defund
police departments.
Critics accused her of doxing critics
to open them up to public
harassment and retaliation.
And on June 28th, protestors
marched toward Krewson's home
along a street called Portland Place
which is blocked with heavy iron gates
and signs marked "Private property."
But one of the houses on Portland Place
is a Renaissance-style palazzo owned by,
you guessed it, Patricia
and Mark McCloskey.
When the demonstrators crossed
paths with the McCloskeys,
the pair countered the
protestors' First Amendment rights
by threatening them with
their Second Amendment rights.
Mr. McCloskey stepped onto
his patio holding a rifle
and yelled, "Get the hell
out of my neighborhood,"
and, "Private property, get out."
After McCloskey brandished his rifle,
Mrs. McCloskey then came
out of the door barefoot
wielding a small silver pistol
and aimed it directly
to the demonstrators.
The entire confrontation
lasted about 12 minutes,
after which the protestors converged
on Mayor Krewson's home for
several hours of protest.
But the McCloskeys
immediately became the couple
who launched a thousand memes and lawsuits
because the McCloskeys
sued the photographer
who took their viral photograph,
the online retailer who used
that photo to sell products
with their unflattering captions.
And while the couple
became MAGA celebrities-
- They were gonna be beat up badly
and the house was gonna
be totally ransacked
and probably burned down,
like they try to burn down churches.
- In June 2021, the
McCloskeys pleaded guilty
to misdemeanor offenses,
Mark for fourth-degree
assault with a $750 fine
and Patricia for harassment
with a $2,000 fine.
The couple was required
to surrender their guns
for destruction, and Mark
McCloskey wasted no time
in blaming the person actually
responsible for all of this,
George Soros.
But in August of 2021,
Missouri Governor Mike Parson
pardoned the McCloskeys,
which he had promised to do
if they were convicted.
The McCloskeys, true to form,
then immediately sued the city,
the sheriff, and the state
alleging the pardon entitled them
to have their guns returned
and fines refunded.
But in February of 2022,
the Missouri Supreme Court
subjected the McCloskeys law licenses
to a one-year probationary period.
After the ruling, Mark McCloskey said
that he was disappointed the
court disciplined him at all
and announced he was considering asking
the U.S. Supreme Court to review the case.
Now, if you are a terrible lawyer
trying to evade public scrutiny,
or just a normal person
trying to boost your privacy,
try today's sponsor NordVPN
because you know that incognito mode
actually isn't incognito, right?
Well, with NordVPN's no logs policy,
your internet service
provider doesn't get to snoop
on what you're searching,
and neither does NordVPN.
With Nord, you can surf
the web anonymously
and your location stays private.
So I can log into my
favorite streaming sites
and see the libraries that are
available in other countries,
and that's just one use case.
And when I'm out of the country
and I try to connect to my
Gmail or a bunch of other things
that I'm logged into,
all those accounts would usually freak out
and tell me that I'm being hacked
by someone in whatever
location that I'm actually in.
So now I just reroute my
connection to the U.S.
and my Gmail and everything else is happy.
And that's one reason to use NordVPN,
but NordVPN has become
this way bigger threat
protection tool, too.
It has all these great
features like blocking malware
and malicious ad trackers.
It's a great tool, and all
this is incredibly easy to use.
So if you'd like to give NordVPN a try,
click on the link that's
on screen right now
or down in the description
to get a two-year plan
plus four additional months
free with a huge discount.
And it's completely risk-free
with Nord's 30-day money-back guarantee.
Again, get a two-year
plan plus four free months
at a huge discount by
clicking on the link below.
And after that, click on
this playlist over here
for more LegalEagle, or
I'll see you in court.